and one of the things to remember is
that all of the passengers on that duck
boat were from somewhere else they were
visitors but Branson is a town where in
some ways there really are no strangers
we saw that over the last two days from
local residents who tried to save the
duck boat passengers to the families who
came here in mourning the mayor of
Branson may have actually said it best
in the hours after the accident quote
were a very resilient community we
bounce back and we take care of each
other whether we know you or whether we
don't know you
Russell McKay drove more than 200 miles
from st. Louis when he got the news
about his friends I was working in the
garage come on let's go we're going down
here I said I gotta see my Rosie I'll
never see her again there's an
outpouring of grief in Branson from
friends of the victims like McKay to
locals some of whom tried to prevent the
tragedy from being worse Pat Cox owns
the State Park marina on Table Rock Lake
he called his manager Roger carpenter
just after 6 p.m. Thursday with orders
to evacuate the marina so when you heard
them that there were duck boats that
were still out on the water what did you
think that time I got a call from Mitch
our general manager said hey I just got
a call from the Showboat Branson Belle
there's a duck out there capsized get
out there he didn't even get all the
words out of his mouth and I was going
with boats how many of you went out
there three boats right away cell phone
video captured the duck boat fighting to
stay afloat in the treacherous waters
what did you expect to see when you got
out there I expect the depot in
lifejackets joking around you're gonna
go grab him out of the water as fast as
we could what did you
when you got there and all we seen was
empty life jackets in empty life rings
and I mean your your heart just drops
carpenter did save two men who had gone
out to rescue victims only to become
stranded themselves they also picked up
three of the deceased you've had 24
hours or so almost to think about what
you saw and what happened what's gone
through your mind in that time it's
shame it's crying shame
there'll be plenty of experts that study
this but I think an ounce of prevention
on the front end would have prevented
most of this from happening we've heard
that from a lot of people actually
around here Pat Cox has owned the marina
that he has there the store for almost
30 years and he said he'd never seen a
tragedy like this on the lake this isn't
the only place obviously where duck
boats are a popular tourist attraction
you can find them from Seattle to Boston
just how safe are they though we're
gonna take a closer look a little bit
later for now we want to go back to
Anthony and Michelle in New York so many
questions about those life jackets Gina
and and and the gesture of leaving the
flowers on the cars that you showed us
is incredibly moving yeah what struck me
the most is again they didn't know these
people there were a few people out here
who knew some of the victims but these
were total strangers I talked with one
woman they're tourists here they didn't
know anything but they heard about what
happened and she said we just we had to
come here it was just something that we
felt we had to do we were so moved and
they were talking to people they never
knew that they said they'll stay in
touch with now forever they feel bonded
together because they all experienced it
in some way they take away certainly
know where those life jackets are grab
them be ready to grab them when at any
moment Dana Jacobson in Branson Missouri
this morning thank you so much Dana